Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up, Prof?
Hello, Walter.
Good day, Martin.
I'm glad we're back.
Yes, I'm glad we're back, too. It's been
rather hectic week, but uh the Lord's
been good to us.
It's impossible to do a week with
actually a minute without him.
I was just thinking earlier and telling
you that if somebody would realize how
some of the things happen behind the
scenes,
they'll
as we do, stand with open mouths and
just wonder at what God does.
how it works. Let's thank him and then
ask a blessing for this. Yes.
Our heavenly Father, we are so thankful
for everything that you do for us in
putting together these discussions.
Thank you for that. We ask that you
enlighten our minds with the Holy Spirit
and guide this discussion because we
cannot do it on our own. We ask this in
Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Martin, the titles are just getting
longer and longer. Why don't we just
write an essay?
Yeah, I know. Even the titles are
you know,
there's a small title or whatever and
then just before we begin,
there's something else on the screen.
Everything changes.
Well, she has become a house of demons.
That's, of course, a a reference to
Revelation chapter 18
about Babylon. She becomes a house of
demon and a house of every unclean and
detestable bird. That means she's full
of evil spirits, right?
And we have to ask ourselves,
how did it happen?
How did it happen?
And then we're going to talk today about
the papacy. Martin, aren't you bored
with that topic already? Like I said in
the previous one, we should just get
used to this because it's not going to
go away until the end. We have we're
going to just be speaking about him
and them for quite a while still.
Well, you can't leave them out of the
equation because there are
two sides to the story
and unfortunately, he's at the head of
the one side. That's it. I mean,
we've got the three angels' messages
Yes. and he's in every one. You cannot
get rid of him.
get rid of him. So, he's again
uh speaking against fundamentalism,
religious fundamentalism in a general
sphere.
In other words, not only fundamentalism
in a Christian setting, but also in a
religious universal setting.
And then he has a problem
with converting people.
Yeah.
Huh? Proselytization, it's it's a major
problem for him.
So,
uh you know, the gospel says, "Go ye
into all the world and preach the
gospel."
And uh
the Lord says, "Go into the highways and
byways and bring in the people until my
house is full."
The Pope seems to have a serious problem
with that.
And that's
creating a problem because then you
actually
moving out Jesus.
And you are creating a command
which is contrary to God's command. Now,
that remember that happened in the time
of Jesus
when the Pharisees
and the prelates told the disciples,
"You will not preach in this name."
Exactly. Huh?
Now, how can the head of a so-called,
let's really call it so-called because
they don't believe in the atonement,
Christian organization
leave out its main role player?
You see, the
the only time they can do that is if
they are not the true church, if they
are not true.
That time when the Pharisees told the
disciples,
"You're not allowed to speak in preach
in that name." You're not allowed to
preach in that name. They discredited
themselves as the true church of God.
Yes, and they locked them up
and the next day they were back in the
temple preaching. What happened?
So, this battle is not going to go away
and uh we will have to get used to it.
And unfortunately, they will have to get
used to it, too. You see, the thing is,
if they want to get this
let's call it maybe
not one world religion, but a world
understanding
understanding of religions, they have to
get rid of Jesus. They have to. And
that's why Yeah, that's why they can't
proselytize. Wasn't he always a
stumbling block?
And he's still a stumbling block. I
mean, this "No one comes to the Father"
sentence
is such a problem for these people.
So, let's go to some Bible verses to set
the stage. Second Corinthians 11,
chapter
verse 14. And no marvel, for Satan
himself is transformed into an angel
of light.
Somehow he has to manage to make
darkness light
and light darkness.
Now, how do you do that? Christ is the
light, isn't it?
So, if you remove him, you have
darkness. That's it. So, this is how he
is transformed into an angel of light
because he turns darkness
into light
and he removes light
so that his darkness is the only light
that's left. Amazing. And you know what?
If you take it back to what we've said
earlier on the two tables of stone, how
the first table was lit
more lit
than in the vision that Ellen White
brighter, yes. brighter.
He doesn't want you
to proselytize, to evangelize. No.
If you evangelize without the light,
Jesus, Yes. then it's not you So, if
what I want to get at is
they've got a very social doctrine.
We've seen it before that you have to
hand out food. We have to do all of
this,
but the light is missing from that. All
right, there are two tables of stone
while we're at this. We're we're off
topic again. You realize that. You
should stop going off topic.
I'm sorry. Well, let's let's talk off
topic just for a second.
Two tables. The first one deals with
God, the second one deals with your
relationship with humanity, right?
Now, he did alter the things in the
second one like he removed the promises
because you can't have God promising if
he's the new God. He wants to do the
promising.
And then he changed some of the wordings
so that you own nothing and he owns
everything. That's the great reset. It's
in in his 10th commandment.
He owns everything, you own nothing, and
you better be quiet and be happy.
All right.
But uh the first one,
the first commandment is very specific
as to which deity we are referring to,
the one who took the children of Israel
out of Egypt. That's the one we're
referring to. That's gone in his version
of the commandments. The second one,
idolatry, has to go because everything
that he does is idolatry.
The third one
is
uh the the law of blasphemy, right?
Now, that's no longer his third one.
That's now his second one.
And I don't know whether today you could
go to Jesuit theater
and look at any movie, whether it be
family or whether it be PG or whether it
be whatever,
it doesn't matter from the lowest,
whether it is for 5-year-olds or
10-year-olds, they're going to have a
blasphemy in it. Yeah.
And
that to me is the very worst. I That's
the one thing I cannot handle at all.
But they make sure that they will
blaspheme.
Yes. And the Jesuits are in Jesuit
theater, Hollywood.
So, we know that that is occult because
the Hollywood is the witches stuff. We
don't want to go into that direction.
And the fourth commandment, he messes up
the entire first table.
Yeah.
And thinks that's fine and the world
says, "Oh, wonderful. Let's obey him."
It's terrible.
But if you if you take that
with Jesus
the commandments are also light.
Of course they are light.
So, if you proselytize without the
commandments and without Jesus, there's
no light. It's a total darkness.
So, when Jesus told the story about the
return of the unclean spirit, Matthew 12
from verse 43.
So, when the house has been cleansed,
now the house of course he's talking
about an individual, but he can also
talk about his church because that's
also a house in the Bible.
So, when the unclean spirit is gone out
of a man, he walketh through dry places
seeking rest and findeth none.
Then he says, "I will return unto my
house from whence I came out."
And when he is come, he finds it empty,
swept, and garnished.
In other words, this individual had
accepted the truth.
Mhm.
And thrown out the garbage. It was out.
The house was nice and clean.
Now it had to be filled
with this.
Exactly.
But if you neglect this
it's empty still. Then it's empty. It's
nice and clean and swept but there's
nothing in it. It's still an empty
house.
And the rules today with squatting
is that if the house is empty, you just
go and move in, right?
So, back come the evil spirits and they
say to each other, "Then goeth he and
taketh with him seven other spirits more
wicked than himself."
And they enter in and dwell there and
the last state of that man is worse than
the first.
Even so shall it be also unto this
wicked generation.
So, it's not talking about an
individual. It's talking about an entire
generation. It's talking about an entire
system. We're talking about the last
days.
Now, it is also true that if someone has
the truth
and then turns from the truth
seven demons worse than the first come
back.
And
they are worse than ever before. I mean,
we just have to look at people that knew
the truth and know the truth
that are in the rock world today that in
public bite off bats heads and things
like that.
Uh
this statement is very very true.
That's it.
It is it is a horrendous thing. Now,
when this happens in the religious
sphere
when it happens to a church
seven times worse than when it was
than what it was before.
Before it didn't know what the truth was
then it learned what the truth is, swept
the house, got rid of all the rubbish
but didn't fill it with the good things.
Seven times worse. That's where we are.
Yeah. So, actually in plain language,
we're speaking about Protestant
churches. We're speaking about
Protestant churches, Catholicism's
house has never been swept. So It was
the Protestants that swept with the
reformation. Yes. And now it's become a
house of demons. A nightmare. She's
become a house of demons.
Well, let's have a look at what's
happening in the world. We first go and
look at a little bit of history.
This was in 2019
when the Pope criticized
proselytization.
"You are not a disciple of Jesus if you
try to convert non-believers." What a
ridiculous
statement. I have never heard anything
more pathetic.
It's true. It's terrible. I mean
it shows you that whatever they say or
what is in the catechism must be above
the Bible because that's not in the
Bible. Now, this disqualifies him as a
religious leader automatically because
it goes directly against a very specific
command of Jesus Christ.
"Never never bring the gospel." Let's
just stop there. What is the gospel?
The good news.
The good news of salvation in Christ,
right?
By proselytization.
In other words
you must not aim to convert. Preach the
gospel. Fill the house. That's what
Jesus said.
So, but Francis says the opposite. If
someone says they are a disciple of
Jesus and comes to you with proselytism
they are not a disciple of Jesus.
"In front of an unbeliever, the last
thing I have to do is to try to convince
him. Never."
Well, he's got a point in a sense
because you can never convince anyone.
The Holy Spirit must do the convincing.
But you have to give the information.
You see, the it's a fine line once
again.
Because there's some truth in this. I
mean, we've always said that there's
this saying that
you must
preach the gospel and if necessary use
words. Yes. So, obviously your actions
have to show that you are are. But the
way he's stating it, it's it's going
over that line because now you're not
allowed to say actually anything. Not
allowed to say anything. And this is
exactly like the Pharisees. You will not
preach in this name. Yeah.
"The last thing I have to do is speak."
What is preaching? Just standing there
with your mouth closed, right?
Francis said, "Instead he stressed, I
have to live consistent with my faith
and it will be my testimony to awaken
the curiosity of others who say
'But why do you do this?' And yes, I can
speak then. Well, I want to know, why do
you do this? Why are all these children
being dug up that have been molested
within the church? Is that a good
witness?"
No. Well, let's not go there before we
must not get hot under the collar. Be
calm
and collected. But that's true what
you're saying. So, they don't practice
what he preaches in any case.
No. And
like he said
it's amazing how clever they can word
something. He Yes. Well, look at all the
pictures of the Popes
standing there with their cigarettes in
their hand or the Cardinals drinking and
partying. Is that a good example of
Christianity?
I mean, like you've showed in that
lectures of yours um
food for thought.
Who owns the breweries? Who owns the
tobacco fields? Who owns the drug world?
They do.
"So, we are not in the times of the
crusades," he said. "Either the baptism
or the sword. This has happened in
history. They also do it with us
Christians in other parts. They are
doing it, but what we did was shameful
because it is a story of forced
conversion
if not respecting the dignity of the
person." Well, he's right there. You
don't can't force anyone
to accept it, but to prevent them from
preaching is diabolic. But what he also
does is he says that if you tell
somebody or want to preach, that's also
actually forcing. So, he once again,
he's
not doing the the the the line justice.
Now, when
you are there in the world
you were playing DJ and all kinds of of
things
uh you saw somebody behaving so
beautifully and decided
"Wow, I'm going to give up being a DJ.
I'm going to give up all of these things
and I'm now going to be a Christian."
Did that happen to you? Not at all, no.
Oh, did somebody preach? Yes.
Oh. I'm sorry. Yes. He had to speak.
Pope, I have to apologize. And he had to
speak loudly.
Let's go back even a year
before that. This is Catholic News
Agency.
"Proselytism versus evangelism. Today,
proselytism is almost universally seen
as a sinister activity when it comes to
religious beliefs.
On several occasions, Pope Francis has
strongly condemned proselytism."
He said, "It is not licit that you
convince them of your faith. Proselytism
is the strongest poison against the
ecumenical path." He's absolutely right.
Exactly. That's where the whole crux is
lying.
He's spot on.
"If you want to have ecumenism,
then you're not allowed to use the name
of Jesus because he's a problem."
That's a problem. You cannot get
ecumenism if he's in the in the mix.
Okay.
And you may not preach doctrine.
Because as soon as you preach doctrine
you have war.
All right. So, this is your problem, Mr.
Pope.
You want to walk an ecumenical path of
compromising truth and error.
Yeah.
You want to sit at the same table with
angels and demons. Sorry, it doesn't
work.
Similarly, the Pope has said proselytism
amongst Christians therefore in itself
is a grave sin.
I think
No, I I'd rather not say what I think.
But well, if I had to say this is a form
of dementia. Yeah, well, this is exactly
He says exactly what what he wants to
say because this
if people accept this
will put you off in the wrong direction
completely. And I think the problem is a
lot of people, even
Christian denominations, agree with
this. Yes. Well, it's either dementia
or it's demonic. What do you say?
it's demonic.
other choice there.
And also he said the church is not a
soccer team that goes around seeking
fans.
All right. But Francis' strong language
is directed at the modern meaning of
proselytism.
This meaning includes using any type of
pressure to convert someone, whether it
is moral, political, or economic. I
agree with that. You don't have to use
pressure. In fact, you may not use
pressure, but you have to preach.
Exactly.
You cannot be quiet. And the main
character has to be there. If it's not
Jesus that's in the center, how do you
convert? Where do you convert them to
then? All right. Did Peter
all the other disciples
have the spirit of God?
Yes.
Were they put in jail for it?
Mhm.
Were they chained on either side to
soldiers to prevent them from speaking
in that name? Were they beaten because
they spoke in that name? Yes. Did they
stop speaking because they were treated
that way?
No. So, I'm sorry, Pope, but you're
barking up the wrong tree.
You can't find another tree and bark
there.
There's nothing new under the sun.
Pope Francis warns against preachers who
sow division online.
We're in trouble. Oh, yes.
We're in big trouble.
Especially because he said even
Christians mustn't proselytize among
Christians. Okay.
At his general audience on Wednesday,
Pope Francis warned against preachers
who sow division and mistrust online.
You know, Martin, I don't believe that
we sow mistrust. We put the facts on the
table.
And hopefully as a consequent people
will mistrust the system. That's it.
There is no shortage of preachers who
specially through the new means of
communication can disturb communities.
I have not come to bring peace Mhm. but
a sword. In other words, Jesus came to
disturb
communities.
They present themselves not primarily to
announce the gospel of God who loves man
in Jesus crucified and risen, but to
insist as true keepers of the truth
"What is the best way to be a
Christian?" the Pope said on June the
23rd.
Well, let me say it again
to the man dressed in white
which is of course his own robe
that if you preach the word of God
then you are telling people what is
right. Mhm.
And if you do not want to live in
harmony with that, you might have a
white white robe under it, but beneath
it you wear the black clothing of a
Jesuit.
Yeah.
And they strongly affirm that the true
Christianity is the one they adhere to
often identified with certain forms of
the past.
Is he referring to the Reformation? I
think so. I think that's what he's
referring to.
the keepers of truth that he's referring
to
is the Bible, the truth that we say sola
scriptura. Yes.
And that the solution to the crisis of
today is to go back so as not to lose
the genuine of the faith.
Yes,
Mr. Pope, that is exactly what it is
about. Go back to the biblical truth
or else you will have to face the
consequences. Not from me, not from you,
but from God himself.
Pope Francis said that these new
preachers can be recognized by their
rigidity which contrasts with preaching
the gospel that makes us free, makes us
joyful.
Well, Martin, we just recorded a sermon
on freedom
and a sermon on bondage.
And in that sermon
I showed that the word slave
and slavery
in the Bible
in the King James is associated only
with Babylon Yes. and not with God's
people.
And I think the rigidity that he's
talking about
aren't Seventh-day Adventists
um accused of being rigid because we
want to keep the commandments of God?
Well, that's what it says. If you love
me, keep my commandments. I don't want
his commandments.
Let me put this quite plain. Mhm.
I was a Roman Catholic. I was an atheist
because I was a Roman Catholic. Does
that make sense, Martin?
Yes, actually it does because that's
part of Babylon. Yes.
Both sides. I became an atheist because
I was a Roman Catholic.
Now, people must do with that whatever
they want.
But then I became a Catholic even though
I was an atheist.
Does that make any sense whatsoever?
Now,
my father's side is all Catholic.
Do I hate everybody on my father's side
including my father?
No, I don't think you hate anybody.
Absolutely not. Do I care about them?
Yes. Do I want them to be in the
kingdom? Mhm.
Absolutely, I want them in the kingdom.
Do I condemn them because they know not
the truth? No. No. Would I try to bring
them the truth? Yes.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
If somebody wants to find the way
to the next city and there is no
signpost that said here is the way
then you're running into a problem, all
right? So, if someone asks directions to
heaven give them directions.
And if you see someone walking towards
hell
then please tell it just tell him,
"Excuse me, you know, there is a better
way. If you go this way, you get to the
celestial city." Pilgrim's Progress.
So, I have nothing against Catholics.
Half my family is Catholics. The other
half is Protestant.
The Protestant half is more stubborn
than the Catholic half. It's just
it just happens to be like that. So,
unfortunately, I have to proselytize
both sides. Exactly. We cannot keep
silent.
Okay. Do I despise the ones that are on
the Protestant side of my family?
No.
No. Do I want them in the kingdom? Yes.
Yes.
Uh
can you reach that kingdom
on a ladder of lies? Unfortunately, no.
No.
The only ladder that works
is Jacob's ladder.
And that represents Christ. Mhm.
So, unfortunately,
I cannot adhere to what he has to say
because it would be contrary to God's
commandments.
He also states that the new preachers do
not know what humility is,
what fraternity is. They don't know what
brotherhood is.
To him,
brotherhood is ecumenism.
Yes. But in the broad sense as we have
seen in Kazakhstan now. Yeah. Take away
Jesus. Take away Jesus and let's embrace
everyone.
Now, there's a vast difference between
embracing humanity
and recognizing that everybody is your
neighbor
and accepting the error
that they believe in
and making that truth.
That is that is a terrible situation. In
other words,
he hates his brother so much
Let me turn his words around. He hates
his brother so much that he is happy to
leave them in perpetual error that leads
nowhere.
That's exactly the turnaround because
what he is saying will lead them to
perdition.
Let's me go to another statement. This
is from the journal America. Pope
Francis, "Religious fundamentalism is a
plague."
It's a disease, Martin.
Interreligious dialogue is an important
way to counter fundamentalist groups as
well as the unjust accusation that
religion sows division,
Pope Francis said.
Excuse me.
What did Jesus say? I've not come to
bring peace, but division. So, the most
divisive person that has ever lived is
Jesus Christ.
He's the most divisive person that has
ever lived.
But, he's the way, the truth, and the
life, and no one comes to the Father
except by him.
That's divisive.
The Pope has recognized that.
So, unfortunately, his war
is not against the fundamentalist who
believes every word.
Because man does not live by bread
alone, but by every word.
By some of the words? No.
Hm?
That's how they see it. Okay. How many
words have been removed out of the new
translations? Hundreds.
Thousands.
Yeah.
All right. So, we have a serious,
serious clash of minds here.
We must beware of fundamentalist groups.
Each religion has its own.
In Argentina, there are some
fundamentalist corners there. He said,
"Fundamentalism is a plague,
and all religions have some
fundamentalist first cousin."
He said.
"To see the dangers of fundamentalism,
Christians must also reflect on their
own history," he said, "including the 30
years' war,
which began in 1618
as a conflict between Catholic and
Protestant states,
and the St. Bartholomew Day Massacre of
1572." Isn't it interesting how he
sweeps the history of this church under
the carpet?
He's not
You know, if it's actually if by his
definition
the Cath- the Roman Catholic Church is
much more fundamentalist church than
what he's saying the Protestants
Yes, they were murderers. They killed
millions, and he's sweeping this under
the rug as though it didn't exist. You
know what? Thank heaven for Sweden
because the Swedes
intervened in the 30 year war
and helped Germany to
stop the tyranny of Rome.
And now he has used his whitewash
and drawn them back into ecumenism. The
children has returned returned to the
mother prostitute,
and he thinks now we'll just forget
about Jesus.
We'll forget about the war, which is
based on the word,
and we will just be in fraternity in
error. Yeah.
And look at how he
twists every time they give new meaning
to words. Proselytization, like we've
seen, and fundamentalism has got a new
meanings
and but he doesn't say it.
He doesn't say it's got new meanings. He
just uses the words and say it's these
people it's not supposed to happen.
I'm afraid the battle between good and
evil will continue until
the last Trump.
"A bit of history should frighten us,"
the Pope said. "Whoever doesn't feel
frightened from within should ask
themselves why. It is important to show
that we believers are a factor of peace
for human societies,
and in doing so, we will respond to
those who unjustly accuse religions of
inciting hatred and causing violence,"
the Pope said. You know what? I'm so
glad he's bringing peace to all the
religions in the world because when they
say peace, peace,
they will be destroyed because they will
again have rejected the stone. Yeah.
Well, Martin,
therefore, it is quite appropriate
that this last meeting about fraternity
that the Pope speaks about took place at
Kazakhstan at the place which they call
the Palace of Peace.
Martin, are we at the very
doors of eternity?
You know what? Look at this. In Kazakh-
Kazakhstan, they've got this one.
They're busy building those mosque and
church and all and the um
Abrahamic
synagogue. Yes, that Abrahamic faith
centers. Not even in Dubai only, other
places as well. This It's all this peace
and safety coming together. Coming
together.
Well, let's look what it looks like.
Pope Francis' message today to the
religious leaders was that the religion
is not a problem, but actually a part of
the solution. He also said that the uh
to combat the world's crisis, we must
care. He stressed that um as long as
inequality and injustice continue to
proliferate, uh there will be no end to
viruses even worse than COVID-19. He
said that uh God is peace. He said that
every human being is sacred, but each
day children born and unborn, um
migrants and elderly are cast aside, and
this is because of indifference.
Well, Martin, the architecture tells us
everything. It's It's occult enough to
have become a house of demons. Hm. Yes,
because there's a lot of sun symbolism
Yes. in this old It's It's totally
occult. Hm.
So, if we have a look at what happened
there in Kazakhstan, I think it's very
important. World religious leaders adopt
human fraternity document.
The world religious leaders today
adopted the human fraternity document
signed by His Eminence, the Grand Imam
of Al-Azhar
and chairman of the Muslim Council of
Elders, Dr. Ahmed el-Tayeb,
and His Holiness Pope Francis of the
Catholic Church in Abu Dhabi in 2019.
So, in 2019,
when it was introduced,
it took up till 2022
to have it adopted, and they all signed
the document.
Now, let's just make sure again, who
wrote the document? Pope Francis.
So, who's the spiritual leader that is
leading the way? Him. Pope Francis. Who
does the Bible say will be the one that
brings the world to the point of peace,
peace, in other words, sudden
destruction? Exactly, the Roman Catholic
system. The Roman Catholic
system. So, this came during the seventh
congress. Do you think they're they're
playing numerology here? I think so.
Of leaders of world and traditional
religions, which concluded on Thursday.
The closing statement of the congress,
which was attended by over 108 religious
and world leaders, underscored the
historical significance
of the human fraternity document,
stressing that it helps promote peace,
dialogue, and mutual respect amongst
people.
Martin, I'm almost at the loss for
words.
In a way,
I'm glad this is happening. I'm I'm
sitting here thinking the same thing.
Because why?
Because it shows you how near we are to
the end.
So, let's look at the Astana Times
Declaration of the seventh congress of
the leaders of world and tradition no
religions.
So, we, the participants of the seventh
congress, spiritual leaders of the world
and traditional religions, politicians,
heads of international organizations,
Does that include the whole package
deal? Does that have the whole world
wandering after the beast?
Absolutely, because they're all
ogling his document.
The kings, the merchants, the religious
leaders recognizing the importance of
addressing global challenges in our
post-pandemic
world. There you have the reset issue.
Uh
climate change, poverty,
organized crime, terrorism, drugs.
Martin,
if every nation
would cut their military expenditure by
10%.
World hunger would be totally
eradicated.
They can still keep 90% of their
military
expenditure. Just 10%.
And then, something to condemn.
Extremism,
radicalism,
terrorism.
It's interesting that he puts
proselytization
into the same category as terrorism.
That's it. And terrorism only got its
true meaning with 9/11. And that's also
was also linked to religious. Yes.
Which lead to religious persecution and
the undermining of human life and
dignity. I don't want to persecute
anyone.
Everybody can believe whatever they
want. They can believe in dumb idols
that neither hear, nor speak, nor talk.
That is their problem.
But if there is a alternative, a better
alternative,
should I not tell them about it?
Actually, we don't have a problem with
people making a choice. No. But they
must be willing to accept the
consequences of their choice. Yes. And
in order to be able to make a choice,
you need to have data.
So, that's exactly what we do. We
provide data on on which people can make
a choice.
Now, Martin, there was a time in your
life where you probably believed in
Father Christmas and the and the tooth
fairy.
But sometime along the line,
somebody said, "Excuse me, you know, the
tooth fairy
is really not relevant in your life."
And then we have a realization, the
urgent necessity for spiritual and
political leaders to work together.
Martin, is that church and state coming
together? 100%.
Isn't that the image of the beast? Yep.
And we have to come to a common position
and declare the following. You cannot
come to a common position when it comes
to salvation.
It's impossible.
So, we note the pluralism in terms of
difference in skin color, gender, race,
language, culture, all expressions of
the wisdom of God in creation.
Religious diversity is permitted by God
and therefore any coercion to a
particular religion and religious
doctrine is unacceptable. This is a
terrible distortion.
This is a travesty of justice.
God permits
sin.
Therefore, we must tolerate sin.
That's the same argument.
exactly. So, they use wording that makes
it sound correct and good, but you must
really put it in place with what the
Bible is telling you.
All right. So, why does God allow
gender problems?
Didn't he create the male and female?
And were they were they not supposed to
be of one mind?
Did he not give certain directives as to
how
they should organize their lives to be
happy? Did humanity adhere to them or
change them completely?
Completely. Didn't they reverse it in
fact? And then they wonder why we have
gender problems.
Race
is the most ridiculous thing
on the planet.
In order to
separate people in terms of religion on
the basis of race is ridiculous.
Language.
Now, who who
confused the languages? God did. Why did
he do it? Because of man's
sinfulness and wanting to be
like God. Okay. So, they were united in
language and therefore they were united
in apostasy. So, God in his wisdom
confused the languages
so that they could no longer be united.
And perhaps they would seek him
in their trials and tribulations. Now,
so actually, what we've got now
is the same as the Tower of Babel. Yes.
Because
then God was thrown out, now they're
throwing Jesus out again to try and get
unity. You have to throw him out. You
have to throw him out. Culture.
So, all of these are an expression of
the wisdom of God in creation.
Now, ask yourselves, Martin, was it like
that in the beginning? No. No.
So, religious diversity is permitted of
God, just like sin is permitted of God.
Therefore, any any negative talk
regarding sin,
if you put that in the place of this,
is not permitted according to the Pope.
And any negative talk in terms of
religion is also not permitted by this
Pope.
And then we recognize the importance of
the value of the document of human
fraternity for world peace
in living together between the Holy See
and Al-Azhar
Al-Sharif
adopted by the UN General Assembly in
resolution so-and-so, is church and
state together.
Oh, wait. Do we have an image? Yes. We
have an image.
Well, let's go to the Pope's
address.
And so that the critics cannot say that
this is conspiracy theory, let's take it
from the Vatican webpage directly.
All right, Martin, here is the opening
address. Isn't it interesting that the
Pope gave the opening address and the
final address? Who's the lead man?
It is
obviously
All right.
So, this is the apostolic journey of His
Holiness Pope Francis to Kazakhstan
opening and plenary session
of the seventh Congress of leaders of
world and traditional religions, address
of His Holiness.
Martin, let's just look at some of the
statements either from his opening
address or his closing address.
And let us see
what the mindset is that is being
introduced there.
Well, he stated,
"It is time to realize that
fundamentalism defiles and corrupts
every creed."
Now, Martin,
we know
that the creed is always a problem.
Correct.
And we have a creed.
But our creed is the word of God.
Yes.
And our particular church denomination
that we belong to, right from the
beginning, the pioneers said, "We have
no creed but the Bible. This is our
creed."
So,
if you have another creed,
like for example, Catholicism has a
creed.
And it's written in their catechism.
And when I attended religious
instruction as a child, I was never
confronted with the Bible. I only had to
learn the creed, which was the
catechism. And the catechism is
absolutely contrary
to my present creed, which is the Bible.
And I have to make a choice. It's a
clash of minds. I either accept the
creed, which is the Bible, or I accept
the creed, which is based on the
traditions of men.
Yes. And Jesus said, "In vain you
worship me,
teaching for doctrine the commandments
of men. You set aside the commandments
for your traditions." That's exactly
what Catholicism does, right?
So, you're not allowed to speak against
the creed.
Did Jesus speak against the creed?
Oh, definitely. Did they crucify him as
a consequence?
That's it. Can we expect the same thing?
Yes, because he said so.
Time for open and compassionate hearts.
It is also time to consign to history
books
the kind of talk
that for all too long, here and
elsewhere, has led to distrust and
contempt for religion as if it were a
destabilizing force in modern society.
In other words, what he's saying, let's
take the history books, like for
example, I've been there history of the
Reformation, and let's throw it on the
trash heap.
Let's take Martin Luther's table talk
and burn it. That's what he's saying.
Yes. Not their history.
No, not like that. No, no. Not the
Catholic Let's just file that under file
13.
These lands are all too familiar with
the legacy of decades of state-imposed
atheism,
that oppressive and stifling mentality
for which the mere mention of the word
religion was greeted with embarrassed
silence.
Religion is not a problem, but part of
the solution
for a more harmonious life and society.
We need religion in order to respond to
the thirst for world peace and the
thirst for the infinite that dwells in
the heart of each man and woman.
So, we need religion.
Martin, we need truth.
Finished. The truth will set you free.
That's it. Not religion. No. Because
religion can be based on dumb idols that
neither hear nor speak.
For this reason, an essential condition
for genuinely human and integral
development is religious freedom.
Now, let's just redefine there because
the Pope has made it quite clear that
religious freedom is only permissible if
it is subject to the common good.
Exactly.
Brothers and sisters, we are free.
Our creator stepped aside for us, in a
manner of speaking, he limited his
absolute freedom in order to enable us,
his creatures, to be free.
How can we then presume to coerce our
brother and sister in his name? I have
never
in my entire life heard a more distorted
sentence than that.
I agree.
Jesus came to set the captives free
from error,
tradition,
self-righteousness,
and transgression of God's law.
He is embracing all of them.
Each person has the right to render
public testimony to his or own creed.
Correct. You can do that, no problem.
Proposing it without ever imposing it.
This is the correct method of preaching
as opposed to proselytism and
indoctrination from which all are called
to step back.
Martin, if you read the word of God and
you explain the word of God, that is a
injunction, it is a command.
And here is his final address.
Pseudo-religious terrorism, extremism,
radicalism, and nationalism. Isn't it
interesting that he dumps that in there
as well?
Yeah, especially if we take into account
the recent Christian nationalism
movement in the United States. In the
United States, yeah.
Dressed up in religious garb,
nonetheless, continued to ferment fears
and concerns about religion. In these
days then, it proved providential that
we could come together once more in
order to reaffirm the authentic and
inalienable essence of religion.
Martin,
this man is happy to embrace
truth and error
in one organization.
The only thing is, I think they have
thrown out the truth.
Not once in any of these speeches was
the name Jesus Christ mentioned.
Can you have truth?
Can you have the way
without Christ?
No. This is a Christless religion.
It's a and fraternity. It cannot It This
is the exact peace and safety
that's based on a lie and has no basis
that can go forward. And in the exact
same month
that they have this meeting in
Kazakhstan and signed this document of
fraternity,
the Pope instructs the Vatican entities
to move all funds to the Vatican bank by
the end of September.
That's interesting.
Let's just say that's interesting. Let's
not be predictive in any way, but it is
interesting. Definitely, something is
afoot. Something is brewing.
Pope Francis authorized wiretapping
phones in financial scandal
investigation. He authorized
wiretapping.
Nixon was impeached for doing that, but
this Pope, everybody accepts that that's
perfectly fine.
It seems it is the new fine because it's
also happening in the United States at
every single level.
There are so many attempts of
impeachment and this and that and the
other and wiretapping. This seems to be
normal. And with the Pope setting such a
wonderful Christian example,
then what can you expect, right?
It's the same, you see, and he he's not
waiting for any judges. If even if a
judge would not give them grant to do
it, he said, "Go ahead." Go ahead, let's
just do it.
Uh here's another article from the 31st
of August
2022 and it comes from Vatican News.
Pope says we are living through Third
World War.
That's interesting, right? We are in a
world war. And it's not the first time
he said this. No. So, he this
interesting wording.
He's speaking of we are already in a
Third World War. Yes.
It's not maybe not a physical war yet,
but economic war is already going on.
Now,
look at look at what's happening out
there. All the attention of the world is
focused on what is happening. Nuclear
things that are happening, threats by
Putin that he will use nuclear weapons.
Anyone that supports the war in Ukraine
and therefore endangers Russian soldiers
can expect retaliation, right?
And veiled threats of nuclear
retaliation.
And the world is looking at all of these
things and in the meantime, they are
setting in place their structures. And
everything else is falling apart. And
because everybody's focus is on the war,
they okay, it's probably the war's
fault.
Yeah, everything is the war's fault.
So, we need prayers for Ukraine. Pope
Francis also turned his attention to the
ongoing war in Ukraine, noting that
today we are living through a Third
World War, one that is being fought
piecemeal.
So,
we have to somehow come to a peace
accord in that direction as well. 23rd
of the September, BBC,
Ukraine war. Putin is not bluffing about
nuclear weapons, EU says.
The EU must take Vladimir Putin's
threats he could use nuclear weapons in
the conflict in Ukraine seriously.
The bloc's foreign policy chief has
said. In a rare address to the nation
earlier this week, Mr. Putin said his
country had various weapons of
destruction and would use all the means
available to us,
adding, "I'm not
bluffing."
And then he called up 300,000
Russian reserves.
So, this is escalating
and the world is basically on the brink.
And on the one hand, they're speaking
peace, peace
on the religious level,
and on the other hand, they're speaking
war, war. Doesn't this sound like the
Bible? There will be rumors of war and
war, etc. And they will be shouting
peace, peace.
Now, and then you add into the mix the
climate change. Martin, this is a stew
and it has various components and we're
cooking up a meal
to serve to humanity.
Yes. Mhm, a tasty morsel.
Let's throw in a new king.
Yeah. Mhm, that'll be wonderful.
Remember many years ago we spoke about
the beamable sustainable princes
Yeah. of which he, of course, was one.
So, now it's a beamable sustainable
king. Now he's a beamable sustainable
king. And he has a mantra
and a musical instrument that he's been
playing all along.
And many things have been written about
him and his economic activities and his
association with the economic forum.
Uh here's an article, Environmental
Health News by Peter Dyckstra, Does
Climate Action Need a King?
The King Charles III has been right
about climate change for decades
and organic farming and biodiversity.
Here's what he wrote for Newsweek in
April.
The world is on the brink and we need
the mobilizing urgency of a war-like
footing
if we are to win. Martin,
are we in a war?
That's exactly why the Pope said we are
in the Third World War. All right. It's
not only physical. How long has this war
been raging? Which one?
The war between good and evil.
For nearly 6,000 years.
Very nearly 6,000. Let's not Let's not
go further than that because, you know,
there are certain corns that will be
extremely painful if we go any further
than that, but let's just say we are
very close, right?
The world is on the brink. It's on a
war-like footing. Maybe we should listen
a little.
Henry VIII began what became the 50-year
process of quitting Catholicism
and founding the Church of England.
That took quite a while to undo, right?
Yeah, 50 year What do you mean the The
The quitting Catholicism.
Yeah, 50 years to get out of it.
50 years to get out of it and then the
Oxford movement to get back into it. And
then the ecumenical movement to seal it
up and the children have returned to the
mother prostitute.
Yes, and so once again those demons are
back. So, if you'd emptied the house,
isn't it interesting that they they they
literally cleaned out the house. They
took out the images, they took out the
altars, they threw it all out as
worthless because they knew according to
scripture it was worthless, and then
through the Oxford movement and that
traitor Newman, they brought it all back
in
and he was honored by being made a
cardinal and then a saint.
Isn't that unbelievable?
It just shows you. He's what he's made a
saint. So, seven demons are back. The
seven demons worse than the first.
So, they've become a house of demons.
It was a strong but imperfect example of
a British monarch laying it down. My
half-serious point here,
if Henry the VIII could turn the
monarchy upside down for his own libido,
Charles can vent a bit on an existential
issue.
I don't know whether Martin whether I'm
being naughty now, but if we look at
Charles's history, I wonder whether
libido played any part in his decisions
in life as well.
Let's leave it at that.
There's one very important point about
King Charles the III.
It was historic
that the kings and the queens had to be
Protestant.
And that they were called defenders of
the faith. Yeah. Yeah. Right?
Now, Prince Charles is the one that
broke that tradition and says he does
not want to be known as the defender of
the faith. He wants to be known as the
defender of faith. Wow, yes, I remember
and he was shown with He had a Buddhist
cloak on and all of that.
He's draw He's worn Buddhist clothing,
he's worn Muslim clothing. He has
portrayed himself as
the great ecumenical religious leader
that embraces all religion. He and
Kazakhstan fit together beautifully.
Wow. And he's representing the
Protestant side. And they've become
Babylon. They're all in a house of
demons and every unclean and detestable
bird.
So, let's see what his role was and how
he fits into Kazakhstan. Today, we are
all keen to hear from His Royal Highness
his vision
for a more cohesive and sustainable
world.
The interdependence between human health
and planetary health
has never been more clear.
As we start a new decade,
it is time to focus on the future we
wish to build. To that end, building on
my sustainable markets initiative,
I am launching the Terra Carta as the
basis of a recovery plan for nature,
people, and planet. More than 800 years
ago, the Magna Carta inspired a belief
in the fundamental rights and liberties
of people.
As we strive to imagine the next 800
years of human progress,
the fundamental rights and value of
nature lie at the heart of the Terra
Carta.
I am calling on CEOs from around the
world
to engage and play their part in leading
the global transition.
To guarantee our future,
we have no other choice.
Martin, the kings of the world will give
their power unto the beast. I don't
know, it just jumps to mind.
And he incorporates the merchants and
Uh you
We have the entire Babylon
confusion
in a
package.
Martin,
the Bible predicts this.
Why is it that people do not take
cognizance of it?
Now, Martin, can you take this climate
issue to the same level You compared it
to the Magna Carta. He now wants to have
a Terra Carta Carta. In other words, the
Earth must be elevated
to the position of deity.
That's Mother Earth worship. That is
pantheism, that is paganism at its best.
It has no room for Jesus Christ. So, he
cannot be the defender of the faith
because he doesn't have it anymore. He
has become defender of
faith.
Anything goes and he has told us what
that faith is.
Paganism
and pantheism. That's his faith. And
does the Pope do the same?
Absolutely the same. He loves Pachamama.
Now, let's see how religious this can
become. Returning to Sinai,
a prophetic call for climate justice and
ceremony of repentance Sunday, November
the 13th,
2022,
Mount Sinai in parallel with the COP27
UN Climate Conference.
Martin, church and state, are they
coming on board with this climate thing?
More and more.
And everything is happening in 2022.
They are in a hurry.
The final movement will be rapid ones.
Very rapid.
So, in November,
between the 6th and the 18th in 2022,
the UN Climate Conference COP27 will
take place on the Sinai Peninsula
in Sharm El Sheikh, Egypt. Religious
communities and religious leaders have a
key role to play in addressing climate
change and climate justice,
which requires deep transformation
within society. Does it require a reset?
A great reset.
On Sunday, November the 13th,
religious leaders will return to Mount
Sinai. Oh, what a beautiful numerology.
We have the venerable day of the sun and
we have the 13th. How Masonic.
A mountain whose memory and meaning loom
large as a place of revelation in the
collective consciousness of
Christianity, Judaism, Islam, and
others.
That's interesting.
It is a site for turning to God and
receiving God's message. Martin, God
gave his message, he wrote it in stone.
If you want to accept it, accept it.
It's the basis of his government in
heaven.
But they want new ones now, don't they?
You see, that's a problem. God never
changes. It's unchangeable. There it is,
written in stone Well, it was written on
stone and
put in the Bible for us. Now, let's see
what these Terra worshipers want to do.
We return to Sinai
in a movement of repentance and quest.
We seek a new vision for humanity. The
old one's not good enough, Martin? No.
And it's endangered existence and we
seek to receive and amplify a message of
life-sustaining living and habits that
humanity needs to hear today. In this
spirit, the project partners will bring
together premier religious leaders from
the world's major religions to gather
upon Mount Sinai
to engage in the first-ever climate
repentance ceremony
and to put forth a prophetic
interreligious call to action climate
justice 10 universal commandments.
10 new commandments.
Well, I'll put this in the realm of
blasphemy. Well, Martin,
I prefer to stick to God's commandments,
which they have all changed
or discarded entirely as many of the
Protestants have. And when they swept
that house clean of all these good
things, they got seven demons worse than
the first. If you just take the the the
the scenario,
God called them, the Israelites, to the
mountain to have this
coven covenant with them.
These people are going on the mountain
and they are going to demand which 10
commandments they want.
They're going to do their own thing.
All right. Now, we've we've looked at
one side of the issue.
Now, we're actually living in incredibly
interesting times.
Because on the one hand, you have all of
this,
and on the other hand, you have this
movement to bring religion back into
politics in a Christian setting in the
United States of America.
And somehow those will all be fused
together in the stew that they are
cooking up.
In this American situation,
there is talk of changing the
Constitution.
There is talk of bringing in Christian
rules and regulations, but as we already
saw, those Christian rules and
regulations won't be the biblical ones.
They will be the papal ones. So, there's
a deception within a deception.
And then you have to have the fusion of
the various religious systems, the
Jewish and the Christian.
And this becomes very interesting.
So, let's just hear what Jonathan Cahn
has to say about where we are in the
stream of time and what he believes is
going to happen. And remember,
he classifies himself virtually as a
prophet
because he constantly says God showed
him.
And then he writes.
Yeah, in a quick nutshell won't do
justice, but I'll give you an idea and
that is that that, you know, the the
world before the gospel was filled with
gods, you know, and the Bible says
behind the gods are spirits. Now, when
Messiah came, he cast out for he had the
power to cast out the spirits. The
gospel came into Western civilization,
the Roman Empire, and literally cast out
the gods, cast out the spirits, the
greatest exorcism in human history. We
have been living in a unique
civilization. That's what's made this
unique. But I won't go into it how, but
Messiah Jesus gave a a warning. And the
warning was if we ever turn away, if a
civilization turns away from the from
God, having been cleansed, knowing God,
turning away from the gospel,
the spirits will return. The gods will
return to their empty house. And that is
exactly what we are witnessing now.
Since the beginning of the 1960s, you
see a turning point, we started driving
out God. Well, it's not going to remain
empty. And the amazing thing is the same
gods that were there in the represented,
the spirits that are represented by
those gods in the Bible. And with
ancient Israel's fall have now
specifically returned to the world, to
America and Western civilization. It's
their national anthem. It's happening to
America now. And and when you look at
the time when America starts turning
away and Western turning away, that's
when all the signs of these specific
gods come back. And we actually I can
actually when I was sharing this going
to share what gods they are. The same
gods that were there when Israel turned
away are the same gods that have
returned, the same spirits right now in
America. I call them the the dark
trinity, you know, I mean and these are
the some the main ones. The first one
and you always see at the beginning of
the list is called Baal or Bel. Means
the possessor or the master or the
owner. And his mission to Israel was to
basically drive them away from God. He
was the alternate God. He was the
substitute God. And it says that he
calls them Bel calls them to forget God.
Well, in America that is what happened
as well. It also it says he calls them
to turn away from the commandments. So,
we have struck down the the 10
commandment. We've taken it from public
square just like Israel. The same kind
of thing. The next one is the wife of
Bel. And the Bel had a wife. In in the
Canaanite um
uh mythology, it was Ashtoreth. You see
her in the Bible, Ashtoreth. That that
was a goddess that is also known in the
Mesopotamia as Ishtar. She She is the
goddess, the principality of sexual
immorality, sexuality. And so, what
happens? Look exactly what happens. In
the '60s, you have the turning away from
God. What happens? We would expect if
she returned, the sexual revolution. And
that's exactly what happens. It's the
It's the paganization of America through
sexuality. You only have a few seconds.
The third one, I'll just introduce it,
is called the destroyer. And this is the
one that caused Israel to offer up its
children on the altars. And I think
everybody's going to already get a thing
of where this is going and we can go
there, you know, but that's that's
that's where it ends up.
So, Martin, he writes about the return
of the gods.
And he states that these gods were
actually demons.
They were driven out by Christianity.
And then they returned.
Now, if he had looked at history in its
completeness,
uh
it wasn't quite as simple as that. Yes,
Jesus brought the truth and it drove out
the demons
in the individuals that chose to accept
the truth.
But those demons still remained in the
rest of humanity.
Because when humanity accepted
Christianity,
they didn't accept the biblical
they accepted a false Christianity under
Constantine.
Yes, that was actually just changing the
names of the demons. Yes, and all of
those deities that he mentioned were
still in the church, but now in a
in a new form. So, the old pagan names
that he mentioned, Astarte and Bel and
all of these, were replaced with modern
ones. And all of those demons were
replaced with saints.
And so, instead of the female de-
deities like Isis, etc., you had Mary
put in the place. Instead of all the
other forms of these deities, you had
various saints put in that place and
they were all mediators.
So, Christianity
was never really true Christianity
except in the mountains and the caves.
So, while all of this was happening in
the world and all of these multiple
religions started forming like Islam
only after 600 AD, etc., all of these
religions in the world expanded and
Catholicism expanded, they were all
paganism.
They were all a house of demons.
Let's put it bluntly.
That's it.
Protestantism cleaned the house.
Protestantism came to the United States
of America.
And in that sense he is correct.
Protestantism cleaned the house and
Protestantism allowed the demons to come
back when they didn't adhere to what
they believed. Now, they are back with
Catholicism in the ecumenical movement.
Exactly. Now, he is saying these demons
are back and exactly what they did in
the past, offering their children to
Moloch. So, we have the abortion
situation in the world, offering
children to Moloch, the sexual
revolution. All of these things came
back.
He's now proposing that they clean the
house and bring back the commandments of
God.
The same as we the other
Protestant denominations we saw want to
do. Yes. And that's the problem. Now,
Martin, when they bring back the
commandments of God, we know that is
another another deception which these
people are unfortunately not seeing.
The commandments that they will bring
back are the papal commandments and not
the biblical commandments. We have a
double blind.
Then we have for the occult world
another Exactly.
blind.
Because the occult world is preparing
for the externalization of the
hierarchy. That means the return of the
demonic forces.
But this can also be twisted. Because
their savior is Maitreya.
Their savior is a Christ.
Yes. It is the return of the Christ.
So, when you look at the pictures of
those, if you go back to some of those
old lectures that I gave on the New Age
movement, for example, where I show what
they looked like, all of these demonic
entities, they all looked like Jesus
Christ.
So, when these demons
manifest themselves
and Maitreya manifests himself, he might
even speak on our televisions. He might
speak at the United Nations of He might
speak at a religious gathering.
When all of this happens, he will be
there like an angel of light and he will
lead people in a direction. And he will
lead them to the false commandments.
Exactly. Saying that he had changed the
the law,
then you know he is a liar and the truth
is not in him because God never changes.
So, Alice A. Bailey already, remember
that she was from Lucis Trust, which was
Lucifer Trust in the beginning, but they
changed the name that it's not so bad.
They said that he will be returning
or that this manifestation will commence
in the year 2025.
I hope it does cuz I want to go home.
Well, it's really building up if you
look at all this
this ecumenical get-together, the
fraternity, all of this,
the demons or gods as he's pronounced it
is really returning. Correct. might
become a reality.
And and what will be affected? She talks
about the educational, the religious,
and the economic
has to change by 2025. Martin, are we
seeing this? Yes.
I mean, the devil also has an agenda,
doesn't he? And this is Lucifer directly
that he's influencing these people.
And so, you have all of these web pages.
We've We're going to talk about it in
other uh talks as well. And they all
concentrate on the year 2025.
This then is the stage of the forerunner
in anticipation of a major global
transition up ahead in 2025.
We're heading for it.
It's the great initiation.
And they have been singing this great
invocation for a long time now within
the governments of the world, within the
United Nations.
They are preparing for this coming of
Christ, but it will be the false coming
of Christ. It will be Satan presenting
himself as an angel of light.
So, Martin, once again, when we put this
all together,
how close do you think we are to the
end?
Well, I think the dates here tell you a
lot.
That we see here.
the door, right? It's at the door. It's
at the door, and the way they are
pushing their agenda. And there has to
become be a time of trouble, so you must
put all of this also into account. So,
the time of trouble
actually is is is active and and doing
its thing when this demonic force is
manifested, right?
So, Martin, we can expect serious times
ahead of us.
But when you see these things, let not
your hearts be troubled. Lift up. Yes,
and and and let's learn
what John tells us. Let's learn it off
by heart.
Let not your hearts be troubled. Believe
in me. Believe. In my father's house are
many mansions, but were not so I would
have told you. I go to prepare a place
for you, and when I have gone, I will
return so that you can be where I am.
Also, Martin, these are wonderful
promises. We are
in the home stretch.
I cannot wait
for all of this to happen so that we can
go home.
I agree with you 100%.
Let's pray.
Loving heavenly Father,
what
tremendous events
are occurring before our eyes.
And people are distracted by wars and
rumors of wars and threats and fears and
economic collapse and bank collapse and
and all of these things so that the
devil can get his plan into place.
Help us to look behind the scenes, to
lift up our heads and know that our
redemption draweth nigh
is my prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.